art
[Musique]
à
jean louis debré gérard larcher ou
encore valérie pécresse
ils avaient tous côtoyé de près andré
damien et sont venus lui rendre un
dernier hommage en la cathédrale
saint-louis avocats mais aussi homme
politique l'homme décédé le 5 mars
dernier à l'âge de 89 ans fut le premier
magistrat de la ville de versailles de
1977 à 1995
l'une de ses réalisations marquantes le
sauvetage d'une marché notre dame
je crois que les versaillais aussi le
souvenir que c'est le maire qui a sauvé
le marché et donc chaque fois que les
versaillais bon sur le marché peut se
souvenir que maître damien a beaucoup
oeuvré pour la rénovation ce marché
après si c'est une occasion de lui dire
notre reconnaissance comme élus locaux
nous savons bien que nous ne sommes que
les continuateurs de quelque chose qui a
commencé avant nous et il a marqué cette
ville d'une empreinte définitive une
personnalité qui aura donc marqué
l'histoire de la ville de versailles
de son côté la présidente de la région
ile de france valérie pécresse se
souvient d'un homme profondément
humaniste avec une très grande liberté
de ton
j'étais un bébé d'amiens comme il y en a
eu beaucoup
dans les yvelines c'est à dire qu'il
m'avait pris sous son aile et il était
avec moi au conseil d'état il m'avait
demi pied à l'étrier quand je suis
arrivée au département il avait eu
d'ailleurs le courage de me soutenir
mois la jeune femme entrée en politique
face aux pontes de son parti
un homme attentif aux personnes qui
étaient dans le besoin et qui ne
manquait pas d'humour comme l'a rappelé
monseigneur éric aumônier tout au long
de la messe
[Musique]